it's honestly a bit surprising that
battlefield 2042 is dropping information
and confirming things right before major
announcements at ea
play but it's also kind of awesome we're
getting clarification and response to
speculation videos out there on youtube
good job community managers
let's dive into more things to know
about battlefield 2042
and what's been just confirmed in an
extensive dice blog post
about robot dog the colin tablet and
penguins just to scratch the surface
as always if you want to hear more about
battlefield come in real soon give us
the old thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel
let's get to it everyone gets a launcher
we kind of knew that already but what's
new is that launchers are now in the
equipment slot
so players will have to choose between
either carrying a rocket launcher or a
metacrate
more on that in a sec dice is balancing
potentially everybody having a rocket
launcher by tweaking their stats like
the ease of use
range and damage but man are we really
gonna have to see if this is balanced
much later in that blog post they hinted
that there would be counters to these
rockets
the quote was something like or how you
stop the enemy from destroying too many
of your team's tanks
which sounds a lot like the game will
either bring back ordnance intercepting
gadgets like the mp aps
or maybe implement active tank
protection systems i can't
imagine vehicles surviving very long
without significant counters on the
field
and honestly there's gonna be a lot of
launchers in play because the choice
between a support item and a launcher
isn't really much of a choice
why would you take a support item and
then run across a tank and have
absolutely nothing you can do about it
plus let's be honest
most players don't pay attention or have
much emotional attachment to tickets and
conquest
so they're just gonna take the death
respawn when they run out of ammo we're
really gonna have to test this out in
beta
could be red or it could be kind of a
mess traditional class items for all
more than one of you pointed out in the
comments after the reveal that we didn't
see any medical or supply crates on the
ground
it turns out that they are in the game
players can customize primary weapons
equipment
secondary weapons and throwables most
notable is that under the equipment slot
now anybody can carry a medical crate or
a supply crate that's a pretty massive
change from previous class specific
roles in battlefield
and shows that even though specialists
generally do fall under that traditional
class system
that system's reliance on people picking
the right class at the right time for
the right situation
seems kind of diminished will
specialists be visually confusing
it looks like squads are limited to four
players but there's no limit to the
types of specialists they can take with
them
you might have a full stack team of
folks who's the medic and then run
around and encounter an enemy team doing
the same strategy
this is reminiscent of the old revive
trains in previous battlefield games
where teams of medics would just keep
reviving each other
and now that any specialist can pick any
weapon that might be an even more
dominant strategy
it also might just get confusing with so
many specialists that look exactly the
same running around
in the blog post dice appears to be
banking on skins making the players look
vastly different
but it's also clear they haven't fully
figured this out yet and are
experimenting with friend faux
recognition
using traditional icons and other
options
just that one person gets the wingsuit
from previous trailers it seems
very much like the featured specialist
listed as sundance was the only person
with a wingsuit and later in developer
interviews they seemed to confirm that
but now we have it in writing there's
only one specialist with this ability
it seems like a pretty big advantage for
sundance who can chase down tornadoes
and use them to jet
far distances across the map even more
useful on maps that don't have tall
buildings
and i guess everybody else just has to
deal with a parachute
building interiors are not that
extensive which could be good or bad
battlefield 2042 looks like it has some
fantastic city maps such as kaleidoscope
in south korea
and hourglass in doha those buildings
will mostly just be used to get up high
though
and pretty much consist of a lobby and a
rooftop you can get to the top by way of
elevators and zip lines
the justification for lack of interior
floors is to prevent distractions from
the rest of the map
which could be fair and reasonable but
it could also be more fun to have
objectives inside of buildings
some other maps will have those
interiors like the colossus ship on
discarded
if this is a good design decision or not
it really depends on how maps
use those skyscrapers and if lots of
players do what they normally do
which is grab a sniper rifle head to the
top and snipe now that's a lot of fun
but not very productive inside
objectives reduce the incentive for
players to do that
expanded out of bounds an issue with
skyscrapers in the past is how many
rooftops were out of bounds
the next posting has more to do with
jets and vehicles but it's a good sign
that the out-of-bounds area of maps have
been pushed further out that means more
room to roam for vehicles and jets but
also players
the vehicle call-in system we finally
got clarification on when players will
be able to call in vehicles players were
trying to figure this out since the
reveal
and see if it was tied to a point system
like more recent battlefield games or
two capturing objectives
the answer is that all players can call
in vehicle drops based on a specific
budget assigned to their team
which changes based on the map and the
mode once you use this ability there's a
cooldown to prevent you from spamming it
so it sounds like there's a system in
place to limit your team from calling in
all tanks for example
based on how much each one costs but if
i were a betting man
you'll probably be able to call in
smaller transport vehicles most of the
time
so you don't get stranded unfortunately
this section also drops some bad news
direct spawning from the deploy screen
into vehicles and air assets is
back i don't know many older battlefield
players who like this system because
we want the runways man it's just so
immersion breaking to spawn into
vehicles directly
and also undermines the value of
capturing objectives like an airfield
maybe newer battlefield players like
this
i don't know how do you feel about it
let me know in the comments below
alright back to good news the vehicle
calling system includes robot dog
so many people wanted to know more about
the robot dog from the trailer
and if it was tied to boris the
specialist most liked the classic
engineer
the answer is that the robot dog's name
is ranger and it's tied to the colin
tablet
ranger can therefore be dropped in by
anyone but not at any time that's
limited by team points as mentioned
earlier ranger seems to be autonomous
and follows the player until issued
orders to scout a location
return to you or follow ranger will also
sacrifice its life for you
it can apparently self-destruct the
robot dog falls under the light unit
category
and goes down easily but it's confirmed
that you can also use it as jeep stuff
you monster
[Music]
all right lightning round on random
vehicle info there wasn't a lot more
here on vehicles but one thing the post
confirmed is that factions will have
their own vehicles
and there are some shared in between
them but at this time there are no naval
maps
how ai soldiers really work we now have
more detail on how ai soldiers will
operate
it sounds like they'll try to blend in
and do many of the same things you're
gonna do
like calling in vehicles capping
objectives throwing grenades and
reviving you
unlike players they cannot be
specialists or use specialist abilities
like the wingsuit
in conquest and breakthrough there's a
cap on how many ai soldiers can be on a
map at a time
generally fewer than the number of human
players that are also there
but that can change apparently when a
match is filling up or is nearly empty
one specific example cited in the post
is that if there's a match that's 120
verse 128
eight bots will join one side to balance
the teams you cannot opt out of bots and
matches and even in solo mode you'll
still be online with bots
cross everything is confirmed
battlefield 2042
is working on cross-platform play and
we'll have testing going on later this
summer
the game will also have cross a between
different consoles like xbox and
playstation
as well as pc which is amazing and
finally
penguins have been confirmed on the
breakaway map they are
it's great i have nothing more to say
about this you do not have to wait long
for battlefield 2042 announcements ea
play live on july 22nd is already
teasing something new from ripple effect
formerly dice la and we already know
2042 will have the
not battle royale mode called hazard
zone as well as remastered fan favorite
maps from previous games
dammavan peak please for more
battlefield 2042 news head on over to
gamespot's youtube page
thanks for watching
you